do you constantly feel tired you
constantly feel like you lack energy do
you feel as though you would be able to
start a great training program or
starting online business or learn new
things if only you had more energy to
use in the evenings if so then this
video is for you so there's a lot of
videos on this topic on boosting energy
levels and there's lots of articles
online but I find that all of them are
somewhat uninspiring they tend to offer
the same tips and advice and to me
they're all things that a little bit
obvious and aren't gonna make all that
much difference you know get more and
better sleep well yeah I'd like to do
that that's that's if I could then I
would eat an orange every day and you'll
be full of energy it's not it's not life
changing so I wanted to look at some of
these slightly more interesting
scientific solutions some things that
maybe you wouldn't have thought of some
things that maybe you can research
further that might have an actual impact
on your energy levels that way you can
train better you can work better you can
learn more you can enjoy your time more
and just everything is better when
you've got more energy so without
further ado let's get started okay so
about sleep the first thing I want to
discuss is improving your biological
rhythms because a lot of people say get
more and better sleep sure and like I
say that'll be great but it's not as
easy as it sounds but how about tweaking
some of the other variables for instance
the time of day that you go to sleep
because some of us are more naturally
morning larks and some of us are more
naturally night owls I'm a night owl
left to my own devices I'll go to bed at
3 a.m. and wake up at 1 p.m. that's just
how I roll I've had to adapt but point
is that if you're going to sleep at a
time it doesn't naturally suit you and
waking up at a time doesn't actually
seat you then you might not be
performing optimally so instead of
trying to sleep better or sleep more
perhaps just try shifting your hours one
back or one forwards and see if that
makes a difference so the time of day
you perform best is defined by what's
known as your chronotype
and in one study it was found that
athletes could improve their hundred
meter sprint time by up to 26% simply by
racing at the correct time that fitted
with their chronotype so this could make
a huge difference you're any
in the gym to the we perform work etc it
makes a big difference
likewise there are things you can do to
try and fix your biological rhythms to
make them more in sync with the times
that you have to wake up and there are
lots of signals and indicators that tell
our bodies when to be energetic and when
to be sleepy one of them is light which
I'll get to in a moment
one of them is food the time that you
eat because when you eat then you
produce more serotonin and this converts
in the body to melatonin the sleep
hormone so when you eat can actually
affect your biological rhythms through
your external sight goobers that means
external time givers and change your
biological clock so one that's more or
less useful for you and that's why if
athletes are playing away if they're
going on a trip on the plane and they
need to deal with the jetlag they'll
often start eating their meals at
different times before they get on the
plane in order to shift their body
clocks and more easily make that
transition
likewise shift workers can benefit from
this so maybe try changing the hours
that you eat
for me personally eating later is better
when I have my big meal at the end of
the day then I'm done because I'm tired
I'm exhausted I'm digesting so one easy
thing you can do to get more out of your
evenings it's just to do something
productive to take those things off your
to-do list before that big meal at the
end of the day which will cause you to
crash and want to go to sleep
[Music]
and another very important external site
giver signal is light so when we are
exposed to light this tells our body
it's time to wake up we produce more
cortisol and we reduce the production of
melatonin cortisol is the stress hormone
yes but it's also very useful for waking
us up in the mornings there's no such
thing as a bad hormone or
neurotransmitter they all have important
roles so in the morning we want cortisol
and in the evening we don't want
cortisol because that wakes us up when
we should be going to sleep so looking
at phone screens and computers that's
very bad for us we all know this it's
hard to avoid if you can get one of
those blue light filters then that can
help on your screen likewise there is
red shift software you can use which
will tone down the amount of blue light
this is like this more similar to the
wavelength of the Sun the biggest change
for me that I find really useful is to
get a daylight alarm citizen alarm that
wakes you up slowly by getting brighter
like a sunrise and it produces again
that blue light that's on the more
similar wavelength to the Sun so instead
of being woken up in pitch darkness at 6
a.m. in the morning by a loud alarm
which triggers a sudden rush of cortisol
that's why it wakes us up because it
stresses us out and then you're
stumbling around in pitch blackness
having been deep asleep moments ago
instead of that you're woken up gently
slowly brought around through lighter
and lighter stages of sleep by a
gradually righter light and then when
you do wake up you're in a room that
feels naturally light and you just have
a lot more energy this is one of the
reasons why people get sad seasonal
affective disorder this is a tiredness
that comes from not getting enough
sunlight not getting enough time
outdoors during the winter months and if
you think about it if you wake up in the
dark and then you drive to work and then
you're working a dark artificially lit
room and then you come home and it's
already dark again and then you just go
to bed having eaten at a weird time then
of course you're going to be exhausted
and a little bit depressed when it's
sunny and light our bodies are producing
more vitamin D thanks to the sunlight
stimulating that and vitamin D though
it's called a vitamin acts more like a
prohormone meaning it regulates the
release of other hormones this again
makes it a very important signal to help
our body get into the correct circadian
rhythm and so if you're not getting
enough vitamin D because you're not
getting enough sunlight you're not also
producing enough DHEA enough
testosterone enough adrenaline and
you're going to be fatigued so one other
tip is to take it
d supplement in the morning but also
just spend more time outdoors even if it
is cloudy walk to the bus even if it's
dark a little bit of sunlight is better
than none and what it might not be very
pleasant at the time in the long run
you'll feel more energetic and hopefully
happier and more uplifted have you ever
noticed how people who spend all their
time outdoors these outdoorsy people
sporty surfers they seem to have
unlimited energy and that is no
coincidence this is also why going to
bed at a consistent time and trying to
eat at a consistent time is important
and then fitting your most productive
hours in during those hours when you're
feeling your best on that routine
because if your body can't get into a
rhythm then you're going to struggle so
as much as possible try to go to bed at
the same time wake up at the same time
eat at a similar time and be productive
at a similar time interestingly one
treatment for depression is something
called wake therapy this means that you
stay awake all night and then many
subjects report that the next day even
though they're tired their depression
has gone and more recent research
suggests that wake therapy can also be
useful for boosting energy levels whilst
you'll have one day in one night where
you're feeling exhausted for the time
going forwards often people feel a lot
more energetic having had that one night
of no sleep this might be something to
do with resetting their biological
clocks in a way that's not something I
highly recommend you trying I'm just
telling you it because it's interesting
if you did think it could be beneficial
for you then I recommend you speak with
your GP about that one
there's also possibility that you might
be sleeping too much if you sleep too
much then you'll get more sleep inertia
that's the feeling of grogginess you
have in the morning some people actually
need far less sleep than others and
there are some people who get by on far
less thanks to mutation on the gene Dec
2 and fortunately that's very rare but
who knows in the future maybe through
gene doping or some kind of miracle
supplement we'll all be able to get by
on less sleep that's probably not a good
thing they did want a quick fix for your
energy levels and for your health in
general and then something that's really
interesting to me at the moment is
breathing correctly and the importance
of that because if you breathe correctly
this can improve your energy by
delivering more oxygen to the parts that
need it the brain and the muscles and
the organs but also it can reduce your
stress and often what we think of as
symptoms of tiredness are actually
stress your body is your physiology is
stressed because you haven't had enough
sleep so if you're worrying about being
tired you're actually making those very
symptoms worse so if you can reduce
stress you'll feel better and more
as well as improving your energy so how
should we be breathing well you've
probably heard if you're interested in
bio hacking that kind of thing the most
of us breathing correctly we believe
through our chests when we should be
moving through our stomachs we do this
by first relaxing our abdomens and
letting our gut hang out and then we let
the diaphragm dip into that space
opening up the bottoms of the lungs so
we can breathe more oxygen into our
chests than we would have been able to
do otherwise but it's not all just about
getting more oxygen and that's where a
lot of people are going wrong see what a
lot of people will do when they're
stressed in order to try and calm down
ironically is to take a big gulp of air
like this and that's not right because
as you can see I'm boosting at my chest
I'm taking in a lot of oxygen at once
but I'm not breathing deeply into the
belly and when I do that I might
actually be over breathing and this is
what a lot of us do all the time because
we've got this incorrect breathing which
comes from poor posture and high stress
levels throughout the day so we're over
breathing we're taking lots of shallow
breaths we're taking lots of oxygen but
we're not filling all the way to the
bottom of the lungs when we do that
although we've got lots of oxygen in our
blood we don't have enough carbon
dioxide and that's actually also very
important for our ability to use oxygen
because mostly our red cells are
saturated with oxygen we don't need more
than we're getting we're getting more
than enough the problem is using that
oxygen and this is where carbon dioxide
comes in handy because you need carbon
dioxide in order to extract the oxygen
from hemoglobin so when you breathe too
quickly too shallowly or when you
breathe big like that you aren't
allowing yourself to do that because
you're expelling too much co2 and that's
when you start to starve your brain in
your muscles of oxygen this is how we
are all the time at the same time my
breathing tends to be irregular and this
sends our signals that vagus nerve that
we're stressed and that something Bad's
happening and instead of having
coherence which is when you can be
ramped up you can be psyched up but you
need to be breathing in a steady in and
out motion in a calm manner and that's
when with that's the difference between
being highly focused on something and
being very stressed about something
you'll be focused in a positive way you
can be focused in a negative you can
address a lot of these issues by just
breathing through your nose a lot of us
breathe through our mouths and when we
do that we have the tendency to take in
these big gulps when you breathe through
your nose
it forces you to breathe more slowly and
more calmly
the same time your nose has a lot of
important functions for your breath it
filters your breath it cleans your
breath of the oxygen and at the same
time it produces more nitric oxide which
is a neurotransmitter and also a
molecule in the body which causes
vasodilation that means it opens up the
blood vessels in order to get more
oxygen and more blood around your system
to your brain to your muscles and it
also actually helps with wakefulness
when we wake up in the morning we
produce more nitric oxide nitric oxide
seems to play a role in the brain where
it increases the area of effect for
action potentials meaning that one brain
area wakes up and it causes a cascade of
wakefulness throughout the brain
point is breathing through the nose is
much better and some study suggests that
there's a correlation between reason for
your nose and your IQ to breathe in
through your mouth could actually damage
your IQ and it could even affect your
attractiveness because it's been
suggested that if we breathe through our
mouths as we younger it causes our face
to become more elongated it ruins our
jaw and this could be why many athletes
have what we were to consider
objectively to be good looks I saw that
we can influence your blood vessels
through your breath I said that we can
enhance the amount of oxygen delivered
to the cells through your breath and I
said it wasn't about taking a deep
breath it was about doing the opposite
and if your breathing for your nose when
you sleep then you should wake up
feeling much more refreshed and this is
where many of us will breathe through
our mouths so some people actually
recommend taping over your mouth sounds
crazy don't do it if you have breathing
issues or if you're a young child or
you're pregnant you know I'm not gonna
be responsible for you suffocating
yourself but people who've tried it go
ahead if you want to say that it makes
them wake up far more healthfully and I
have a kind of phobia fun facts about me
where I don't like sticky things I just
don't like things being on me okay so
tried like tying a scarf around my face
I'm not gonna lie it's not something I'm
gonna do regularly because my wife isn't
attracted to me when I do that I do
think that fortunately I am someone
who's read through my nose more which
might be why I have a good your line and
a massive nose a hilar comment you check
out the TED talk by Patrick McGowan
if you'd like to hear more about this
it's really interesting and he's got a
book called the oxygen advantage also
really interesting another breathing
technique
relevant here that can increase your
energy that I'm definitely gonna go into
a lot more detail on in future is the
wim HOF technique this is a method of
essentially intentionally over breathing
in order to saturate your blood with
oxygen but also decrease the amount of
carbon dioxide this makes it harder for
you to use all that oxygen and that in
turn creates a sudden spike in
adrenaline at the same time it alkalizes
your blood makes you better able to
withstand extreme cold apparently and
that surge of adrenaline can help boost
your performance and give you a big
pickup in terms of energy helping you to
exert yourself better than the gym
increasing endurance and maximum
strength even at the same time it seems
to support the immune system a lot of
people swear by the wim HOF method and
use it every morning to give themselves
a kind of jumpstart kind of kick of
energy like I say I'll go into this in a
lot more detail in a future video but
you know what will also boost your
ability to use oxygen and to feel more
refreshed energetic as a result is
cardio and this is something people
don't talk about when they're talking
about boosting energy and I don't
understand that they'll say things like
take a cold shower and wear socks in bed
to thermoregulate
all fine tips but like I say we're
talking marginal improvements here
whereas getting more exercise and cardio
exercise in particular is going to widen
your blood vessels it's going to improve
your heart's ability to deliver blood
and oxygen around your body it's going
to increase your video to max min you
can use more oxygen and increase the
number of mitochondria in your cells
mitochondria being the energy factories
that allow you to use glucose and it's
been suggested that the density and
quality of mitochondria might be the
main difference between young children
where they've got so much energy and
elderly individuals who seem a lot more
tired and exhausted steady-state cardio
so running long distances or cycling
long distances is best for lowering your
resting heart rate I've talked about
this before it increases the size of
your left ventricle so that you can pump
more blood and oxygen around your body
with each pump and that means that
you'll be calmer and it means that
you'll have more energy flowing into
your brain for you to use throughout the
day
high-intensity interval training on the
other hand seems to be particularly good
for increasing your vo2 max the ability
to use a large volume of oxygen with
each breath and both will increase your
mitochondrial efficiency
and number so like I say it's not fun if
you're tired it's the last thing you
want to do but it's the biggest change
you can make probably is to increase
your cardio fitness speaking of
increasing your mitochondrial countin
function there of course many nutrients
which can do this
things like l-carnitine lutein which
I've talked about on the blog quite a
lot I'll leave the link in description
down below resveratrol the coenzyme q10
creatine these things improve your but
it's use ATP and increase the function
of the mitochondria so you can use
glucose more efficiently there's plenty
more out there curcumin also been shown
to improve your glucose sensitivity and
this is the next tip it's just to
improve your nutrition in general and in
particular to get lots of healthy
vitamins and minerals and all those
other key nutrients and if you can't get
them from your diet then supplement
because that's a great next best thing
omega-3 fatty acid there's a world of
good for you I talked about this in a
recent video briefly I might do a whole
video on it but not only does it improve
cell membranes permeability meaning that
signals and neurotransmitters and
hormones can pass through yourselves
more quickly it also reduces
inflammation information in the brain is
thought to be responsible for brain fog
which is what makes you feel tired and
groggy and struggle to focus it also
improves DHEA production which is a form
of adrenaline which increases
testosterone and reduces cortisol
cortisol being the stress hormone and
like I say cortisol is useful for waking
up but when it is continually produced
throughout the day that's when we feel
hyper some won't breathe funny that's
when we feel strung out and that's what
we often associate with the symptoms
that we call tiredness I very recently
uploaded a post to the bio near where I
shared a stack of supplements I've been
using recently that's helping to burn
calories burn fat maintain muscle and
increase my energy levels so check out
the link down below if you want to see
more on that the three supplements on
that list that I recommend the most that
I think have had the biggest benefit for
me are in not at all forskolin and BCAAs
so in not at all is a supplement that
can increase your ability to utilize
energy it's sometimes referred to as
vitamin b8 it prevents
storage Bruce Lee account used to use it
but at the same time it also increases
the density of the receptors in your
brain for the neurotransmitters dopamine
and serotonin and this can increase not
only your feel-good factor your state of
calm and lower stress but at the same
time improve your motivation and your
energy that way and as we'll see later
in this video that's a big part of what
it means to increase your energy for
scaling meanwhile can raise testosterone
which helps to reduce stress as well and
boost energy levels in that way at the
same time there's also a vasodilator
that effects specifically the brain and
helps to increase blood flow to the
brain and that can massively increase
your energy a lot of people say it's
like a cold shower for the brain and
another one that does this is
vinpocetine but forskolin has a lot of
other benefits too particularly
nootropic benefits finally BCS at BCAAs
have branched chain amino acids and
these can act as a source of energy they
can prevent your body from breaking down
muscles so they're great for a lean bulk
but at the same time once again they
make you more energy efficient and I
personally think they've had a big
difference they were effective in a
pre-workout and I've had a lot more
energy in my gym workouts I think partly
thanks to this combination of
supplements caffeine might be great in
the short term for boosting energy
levels but actually it could be
responsible for some of the sleep
inertia that you're feeling because some
people say that one of the reasons wake
up groggy is actually cause we are
experiencing caffeine withdrawal because
we drink it all through the day let me
go all night without it so if you do
experience a lot of grogginess in the
morning perhaps try stopping caffeine at
3:00 just cut them down a bit and see if
that helps you and the last thing I want
to discuss is perhaps the most important
and that's the role of emotion in your
energy levels because you probably know
that when you're depressed you're far
more likely to feel tired and sluggish
and low on motivation and the opposite
is also true when you're passionate and
infused and engaged then you have more
energy a great example of how this works
is to think of sobriety save say you've
been on a night owl or a party you've
had a lot to drink and you're feeling
pretty tipsy then a fight breaks out or
your friend falls over and hurts
themselves what happens normally you
sober up quickly and get your sensible
hat on and you start to be able to make
decisions you forget that you were ever
drunk your brain has an ability to focus
to wake up when it needs to then you get
home you crash out later on with all
that alcohol hits
once the same thing happens when you're
tired and unmotivated when something
important happens they need to focus on
you forget all about that tiredness it's
very psychological and if you think
about someone like Arnold Schwarzenegger
Will Smith or Dwayne the rock Johnson
these are people are just full of energy
and enthusiasm and when they walk into
the room they're just you can feel the
energy and the passion brimming from
them can you imagine any of those guys
having an off day they never seem to be
dull and uninterested they never seem to
be slow and tired and that's because
they're so focused on what they're doing
they love it so much but you can feel
the energy coming from them and they
have that motivation to get up every
single day and to hit the gym or to go
and do interviews etc whatever it takes
if what you're doing is something that
you're if you're going to a job that you
hate and of course you're going to feel
sluggish in the morning you're gonna
feel tired now unfortunately we can't
all choose our jobs I will say that if
you feel that way every morning then
perhaps you should consider a change of
career but more to the point you can
also try and just find the passion in
what you're doing wherever possible try
and remember why you're doing it try and
focus on the end result or the thing
that attracted to it in the first place
this can help to give you more of that
energy and that motivation to get on
through and conversely think about the
role of stress stress is an energy
drainer emotional stress is so much more
tiring than physical strain go to the
gym and yeah you'll feel tired
physically but you'll still be able to
do something productive have a great
conversation when you come home have a
hard day at work where everyone's
shouting at you where the world is
collapsing around you and come home and
worry about debt and about your
relationship because you're arguing and
you're gonna feel exhausted you just
want to climb under the covers and go to
sleep stress massively tires you out so
do everything you can to reduce stress
in your life if you want to boost your
energy levels that can be as simple as
thinking about your commute to work
because a lot of us we have the most
stressful start to our days other than
waking up into that dark room by that
loud noise we then get on a train where
it's a busy anyone's coming at us which
is one of the universal fears that all
humans have is of people walking at us
that then increases our stress levels
and then we spend the whole day stressed
at work and then we come home and no
wonder we want to crash out and just cry
under a blanket and then how you're
supposed to hit the gym and feel
enthusiastic or start
business or write a novel when you've
had that all day again there are ways
you can reduce your stress levels
throughout the day small ways but if you
feel like that and then maybe consider
making some larger changes and a lot of
this does come down to prioritizing the
things are important to you because
that's the final tip the final point I
want to make energy is finite and we
forget this we think that time is the
problem we say oh if only I had more
time then I'd be in great shape if only
I had more time then I'd start a home
business I only had more time I stay in
contact with my friends but I bet you
have time I bet you've watched the box
sets this month I bet that you spend
time just staring at YouTube or other
things you shouldn't really be doing and
that's because all there you have the
time you don't have the energy and
because you don't have the energy you
don't have the enthusiasm and the
motivation energy is the problem and you
can do all these things that I've
suggested and you can do all the things
on other websites and in other videos to
boost your energy levels and I hope that
some of these will make a profound
difference but at the end of the day
there's still a limited amount at the
end of the day you need that time out in
order to have the energy when you come
back to work and so you need to
prioritize and that might mean doing
less it might mean saying no sometimes
it might mean saying if I want to do
this then I can't do this so many people
tired and exhausted and they say to me
and they're overweight and they say to
me I'm gonna start your training program
five days a week and now and a half each
session going to and from the gym and
I'm like so you're already tired and on
top of that you're now gonna spend 15
hours of your week working out and
exerting yourself it's not going to
happen
you need to cut something else out of
your life to make space for that soap
some of this has been useful and
interesting for you I'm gonna come back
to a lot of these topics because I kind
of just ran through a whole bunch here
I'll definitely be speaking about
breathing again and the wim HOF method
for instance which a lot of people have
had a lot of luck with I'll be talking
about flow States and that's linked with
the motivation in the heartrate coherent
stuff so stay tuned if you want more on
that also of course I'll be doing more
of my usual stuff on fitness and
productivity technology so if that all
sounds good then thanks a ton for
watching and I'll see you next time bye
for now